hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel today we're going to be making a
video on Google faps oh sorry I was
thinking about something from earlier
today we're going to be making a video
on Google Maps and uh it is going to be
a long one so get some popcorn sit back
and enjoy the show okay so uh as most of
you know uh Google Maps is a service
that you use to get from one place to
the other uh I would imagine just about
everyone watching this video has
probably heard of it unless you're
living in China in which case you
probably don't have YouTube in the first
place so you're probably not living in
China anyways Google Maps like I
mentioned one place to the other so one
route that I happen to take very
frequently is from my house to Sydney
Sweeney's house we're good friends and
uh it takes 26 minutes to get there and
here's the route from start to finish
and Google Maps is going to tell me the
directions to get there so note that
there's an ETA and note that there is a
route as well so in order to formalize
these problem requirements let's turn
them into three different statements the
first is that we obviously want to get
the quickest possible route between two
arbitrary locations now the truth is
Google Maps isn't always going to give
you the quickest possible route it's
going to make a trade-off between
finding you the best possible route and
also getting you good latency in terms
of figuring out what route to take so uh
worth noting that there the second thing
is that we want to be able to provide an
ETA for this route and the third thing
is that as things like traffic or
weather or anything like that change we
want to be able to incorporate that into
an updated
ETA cool so hopefully that makes a
decent amount of sense okay the next
section I'm going to call capacity notes
the reason being that I'm not actually
going to blatantly estimate anything too
serious here but I'm going to provide
some baseline figures and you know maybe
you can run with them to to get a sense
of the type of scale we're actually
going to be working with here so let's
imagine our system as a massive uh graph
right of nodes and edges because that's
basically what what a road system is
you've got a bunch of roads which are
edges and then a bunch of different
places which are nodes and frankly some
of the intersections might be nodes as
well because anytime that uh you know
you can go from one road to another road
we probably want a node representing the
fact that uh there are multiple edges
connected to it so if we decided to
model our problem where every single
intersection is an edge every single
highway exit is sorry every single
intersection is going to be a node and
every single
uh Highway uh exit is going to be a node
and every single place or address is
also going to be a node on our map then
all of the roads that we can take
between those are going to be edges and
so for what it's worth uh just doing
some quick Googling there are about 16
million intersections in the USA alone
there's about 200 million places in the
USA alone if we wanted to scale that up
that would probably mean that we are
looking at like 50 billion different
nodes on our map and then you've got
tons of Roads connecting them as well so
again like I said I'm not going to do
any sort of particular capacity estimate
here because it would be super handwavy
the point is we have a crap ton of data
and for all of these nodes in our graph
and for all of these edges we're going
to need a decent amount of metadata
their latitude their longitude an ID
potentially a name uh things like that
uh the travel time that it takes to
actually go uh from one road to another
and so basically the gist is that uh the
only reason I say this is because our
graph is very very unlikely going to be
fitting on a single partition I'm not
going to try and estimate how many
partitions we're going to need we're
going to need a lot but uh it does tend
to complicate things when we can't fit
everything on one partition and that I
think is worth
noting cool so the first thing that I'm
going to do is actually qu do a quick
overview of Dyer's algorithm because uh
for those of you who have not thought
about this one in a while and I wouldn't
blame you it rarely comes up in our
day-to-day jobs uh dter algorithm is one
of those types of lead code problems
that you probably just have to know so
if I have a starting point on a graph
and I have an ending point on a graph
dous algorithm basically says we're
going to iterate through all of the
nodes in this graph splitting them into
three different types of areas we
basically are going to have a settled
set which is basically saying okay if
this node is in the settled set I know
the shortest path from the start to that
node we also have the frontier set which
is basically saying okay I've seen this
node but I'm not sure if I've seen the
shortest path for it and then there's
also the unvisited set which is saying
basically I haven't encountered that
node in My Graph just yet so for every
single iteration of uh Dyer's algorithm
basically we're going to start with the
start point and say all right well
obviously the start point is zero
distance from the start that's simple
enough now what we're going to do is put
this in the
frontier and then from there we're going
to take the element of the frontier at
every iteration that is closest to the
start point which on the first iteration
is going to be the start we're going to
find all of the edges that connect to
other points from that current point
right so in this case those edges are
going to be this guy over here this guy
over here this guy over here so now
we're looking at b c and d right so
we're putting b c and d into our
Frontier we're putting the start point a
over here into our settled set we know
zero is the shortest distance to it and
then now on our next iteration we
basically say okay this guy is our
Frontier which is going to be our
current node that we're about to put in
the settled set we would actually use
some sort of uh ordering where we
basically take the node that has the
shortest distance to the starting point
so if you recall uh note that B has a
distance of two c has a distance of four
and D has a distance of six so that
means B is going to be the next node
that we take and from there we now look
at all of the edges out of B so from B
we're going to add C again to the
frontier set it's already there however
note that the distance to C going
through b is actually only three where
as it was four before so now we update C
to have a distance of three D maintains
its distance of
six and then also now all of a sudden we
knowe that we can get to e but it's got
a distance of 10 so that's going to be
our Frontier set and we basically keep
going through updating all of our
distances in the frontier set and
pulling out the element of the frontier
set that is closest to the start point
until we eventually finish and reach the
distance at the end point so of course
the time complexity of this algorithm is
going to depend on our implementation
basically how we're actually going to
model the frontier set we can use
something like an array list we can use
something like a priority CU and these
all definitely are going to have
trade-offs but the point is as the
number of vertices and edges change in
our graph as they increase Dyer's
algorithm is going to become a lot
slower and this is something that is
important to note the the reason being
that let's say I want to go ahead and
find the distance from myself over here
in New York and then I want to find the
shortest path over here in let's say
Oklahoma for those of you who are not
living in the United States this is my
very poorly drawn map of the United
States hopefully it makes a little bit
of sense but in reality these are
thousands of miles
apart and the problem with that is that
when you have to Traverse thousands of
miles and you have tons of nodes and
tons of edges that you have to consider
consider dyous algorithm is simply not
going to be feasible you need to do
something better than that we need to be
able to minimize the surge space right
and only basically consider certain
roads which are very clearly going to
get us closer to our Target and not
consider all of these very short roads
and these back roads and things like
that so the next thing that I'm going to
bring up as a concept is something that
Google Maps actually does which
officially is dubbed contraction
hierarchies so the idea here is we can
basically do two things things to reduce
the search space for our Dyers algorithm
the first thing is that we can basically
just straight up remove certain edges
right if I look at this edge here from
node a to node C down on the bottom I
can just get rid of it it's not the
fastest path between a and c and in
addition to that no one else actually
uses it so getting rid of it really has
no cost to us but keeping it makes us
have to consider it in D algorithm which
is bad we don't want to do that so we
want to get rid of unimportant edges
another thing that we can actually do is
get rid of certain nodes and edges
entirely by creating something known as
shortcut edges so a shortcut Edge is
effectively just going to be a cached
Edge between two different points and we
can create one whenever we're removing
certain other roads or certain other uh
points uh connecting those roads so for
example we could create a shortcut Edge
right here of uh length four because we
know that uh basically you know getting
rid of all of these intermediary nodes
is is not really going to affect our
traversal and so the issue with
contraction hierarchies is they're
definitely not simple right like uh this
is something that a lot of research goes
into there's no perfect turistic for how
to reduce your search space but ideally
the general gist is that you want to end
up having a bunch of edges which are you
know important and basically the
majority of routes are ultimately going
to be going through right so for example
if I know that a certain uh road is
going to be very fast and is going to
lead me to my destination a lot of the
time and it's also going to help other
people get to their destination a lot of
time we probably want to keep it a good
example of that would be a highway
generally speaking if you have a bunch
of traffic lights that's going to be
slow because you have to stop at them
all the time but highways are generally
faster and a lot of people use them so
this type of contracted map that we want
probably does include the highways and
it probably looks to get rid of all
these back roads and roads with street
signs cool so another thing to note
that's very important is that we
actually want multiple levels of these
contraction Ed graphs right the reason
being that um you know let's say I'm in
the United States I want to drive from
New York to California for those of you
who are not living in the United States
New York and California are on opposite
sides of the country it is a very very
long drive and takes about a week if I
want to run dyras on that it's just not
possible right and on the other hand if
I wanted to just go and stay within New
York that might be a little bit easier
and if I wanted to drive 10 minutes from
my house that might be even easier so
the gist is we can actually have
multiple levels of uh graphs that are
increasingly sparse so that we can uh
make our search space a little bit
better right so again the idea is uh if
we have a ton of contractions it's
probably just going to end up being
major highways which makes a lot of
sense right like if you had a map a
physical map and you know this was back
in the 1950s and you're driving from one
place to the other you probably weren't
looking for back roads you were just
looking from Highway to highway to get
you to the general area that you were in
and then finally once you get very close
you can look at at all those back roads
and get to your exact location cool and
then the idea here is just again no back
roads uh which potentially might lose us
a little bit of time here and there if
we encounter some traffic on a highway
uh but ultimately it is going to make it
such that we have a much smaller dyst
algorithm to run and as a result we can
actually fetch our route in some
reasonable amount of
time cool so let's actually take an
example of a graph traversal that might
go on so the first thing is here's our
start Point here's our end point let's
imagine that this is actually a pretty
far distance apart maybe a few miles so
just running typical Dyers algorithm
over the entire graph is not going to be
feasible instead we have to actually use
our sparse graph in order to get us
there and our sparse graph only contains
these nodes with the boxes in them right
and the edges connecting them because
those are going to be the kind of
important roads that ultimately are
going to get us the majority of places
that we want to go so let's imagine my
start node is right over here the first
thing that I want to do is actually go
ahead and do one a dyous search to any
of the nodes in the sparse map so I can
do that pretty easily I just run a dyra
on my non-compacted graph and because in
theory there should be a sparse node uh
close enough to us it shouldn't be too
bad of a search right so maybe I've got
one result over here and maybe this
takes me 3 minutes to get there and then
if I decided to take a left over here
and go up maybe this route takes me 8
minutes similarly uh from our end
position we also want to do the same
thing we want to take another uh dyous
algorithm and find the closest points in
that sparse map so let's say you know
we're uh 1 minute away from this guy
over here and we're 4 minutes away from
this guy over here and you know perhaps
something like uh 7 minutes from this
guy over here then from there we have a
variety of start points and end points
that we can actually get to and what we
can now do is just run a dyous Sur
search on the sparse
map and so by doing that uh we can
actually find the distance between these
various sparse points uh or their start
point in the sparse map and the variety
of end points in the sparse map and then
once we calculate all of those distances
we can just go ahead and take the
minimum which is great because that is
going to allow us to use a significantly
smaller amount of uh searches in order
to get the result that we want otherwise
uh this would be a massive distance you
know we would have a bunch of points all
the way through here and we would have
to check all of them right that's very
inconvenient cool so the next point that
I want to make because uh it's pretty
easy to learn about contraction
hierarchies but uh one emphasis that I
always like to make in these videos is
actually you know the systems designed
choices right what database do we want
to use for our data so as far as the
base graph goes I think ideally we would
probably want to use a graph database
when I say the base graph I mean the
uncontracted one right so literally just
all of of the nodes all of the edges the
reason I say use a graph database is
because probably storing this memory is
going to be out of question uh it's
pretty huge and that would be really
expensive to keep it all in memory and
the reason I say a graph database is
because we have to run traversals and so
even though you could do something known
as a non-native graph database so for
example you know you would use a many to
many relationship in a SQL database to
represent edges that ultimately is going
to be relatively slow the reason being
that if we wanted to do that the way we
would represent an edge is by using an
index over the ID on a directed Edge or
something like that and the problem with
that is that that table is actually
going to get slower as our data set
grows in size because indexes basically
rely on just sorting things by the ID uh
in order to find something in a sorted
list we have to binary search it and if
we have to binary search it that is a
logarithmic algorithm relative to the
size of the list and as that list grows
bigger our traversals go slower on the
contrary something something like neo4j
is known as a native graph database
which basically means that it actually
uses pointers to all of the nodes on
disk uh to help represent edges and as a
result of that uh every single jump from
one node to another via an edge is going
to be in constant time as opposed to
logarithmic time so even if we have a
huge data set things in theory should
not get slower so the next question is
what should we actually do with our
sparse graphs well ultimately we should
probably store them in neo4 okay however
these things are technically smaller and
if they're small enough Perhaps it is
actually feasible to store them in
memory the reason I say this is because
of the fact that these sparse graphs are
probably going to be used in a lot of
the queries right uh obviously um you
know we're always going to have to use
the base map because it's unlikely that
our start and end point are in one of
the sparse graphs however uh we're
probably going to have a lot of
partitions of that base graph whereas
you know for our sparse Maps we may have
fewer partitions so all of of those
partitions are probably going to be
accessed quite a bit more and so we want
to keep those read speeds as quick as
possible and keeping them in memory or
effectively caching them could be very
very useful for us there so again we
could keep a backup in neo4j but
depending on how many shards we have uh
keeping these guys in memory could be
very very huge for us cool the next
thing I want to touch upon is
partitioning because I just started to
mention that so the first thing that we
should note is uh we probably do want to
be partitioning by geohash so I've
covered geohashes plenty in the past um
and so I don't really want to go into
them too much in this video I'd highly
recommend looking at the Yelp video that
I made recently or the Uber video that I
made uh if you want uh more information
on those but the general idea of a
geohash is that we basically split our
map into many different pieces and
basically the geohash is an ID assigned
to every single point in our database
such that points that are close to one
another have very similar geohashes
which make them feasible for range
queries if we're actually looking for
close points uh from a given point in
our database and so by partitioning by
geohash we know that typically you know
if I'm going to run a DTR search I'm
going to do so starting with the points
that are closest to me so partitioning
by geohash is going to ensure that the
majority of my dyra search is going to
occur on the partition that my start
point is located on so ideally that
should be very useful the problem with
partitioning by geohash is that
objectively certain ones of these uh
partitions are going to get more traffic
right like in Oklahoma over
here versus New York
City there is a pretty significant
difference in terms of how much traffic
you're going to be getting because there
are a lot more users in New York City
using Google Maps compared to Oklahoma
there's a pretty small population and
that's assuming that we're using you
know equal geohash sizes so what you
could do is a couple of things for one
you could dynamically size uh our
geohash partitions right so rather than
using this whole big box right here New
York City is just a very small box and
that way you end up getting pretty even
load between these two another option
that you have is for the most part these
things are going to be read only and so
what we could do is actually go ahead
and uh you know just add more replicas
for the hot partitions so you know maybe
this guy over here in northeast America
which is going to get a lot more traffic
could have 20 replicas and OK Oklahoma
maybe has two now for what it's worth I
did say that these are readon partitions
but the truth is that they're not we do
eventually have to update the weights of
the graph with how long it takes to
actually Traverse a given Road
especially as incoming traffic data
comes in and so having a ton of replicas
is not necessarily the most convenient
thing uh if we want to be able to update
those semi easily of course it's a
trade-off but we can discuss that one
later cool the next thing I want to talk
about is actually going to be updating
etas because this is where things start
to really get tricky so I guess the
general idea here here is that we can
start to figure out the speed of a
driver and actually update the weights
of our graph according to it right so
let's imagine that uh you know I have
the following Road I've got this guy
length one this guy length one this guy
length one this guy length one so it
takes one minute to drive on all of
those roads and all of a sudden we have
a car accident right here and now
instead of taking one it takes time six
now note that we had a short a shortcut
Edge on this road before right this guy
right here which previously had Time 4
now all of a sudden that shortcut Edge
has time 9 because we just added five to
this segment over here however if we
actually look at it there's actually
going to be a shorter path from our
start
point to our end
point by taking this guy over here this
is only going to have a time of length
eight and so as a result the question is
what do we do about our shortcut Edge
now that we actually have to update our
ETA so this is all going going to be uh
part of the challenge of updating our
ETA and we're going to go through all
the steps of actually figuring that
out cool so the first thing is actually
going to be calculating how fast a
driver is going so even though modern
phones do tend to have accelerometers
they can't just automatically calculate
your speed you do have to use a couple
of GPS signals and then you know get the
displacement over time right so if I
have a GPS ping and it gives me a lat
long and then it also uh gives me the
time stamp associated with that GPS ping
basically we would do is say you know
distance over time is equal to Velocity
and then that's how fast our car is
actually going to be moving cool so then
the question is well okay now we have a
value that we've gotten for how fast
we're moving but what road are we
actually on right because ultimately we
need to attribute the speed to a
particular Edge in our graph or else
it's useless to us we need to update the
The Edge on that graph so this is not
something I want to go too in depth on
because uh I already have in the Uber
video and it took me about 30 minutes to
do but if you recall we can basically
model this problem with a hidden marov
model where every single Road has a
certain transition probability right so
if I'm on one road there's a certain
probability that I'm going to stay on
that road there's a probability that I'm
going to switch to another road and then
every road also has an emission
probability for seeing a GPS signal now
you might be asking yourself well why do
we need this GPS signals from phones are
imperfect so we might get this GPS
signal right here and we actually don't
know if it's coming from this road on
the left or this road on the right
however it right after that if we happen
to get this GPS signal number two uh
we're pretty confident that it was
probably from this road over here
because it's unlikely that if you're
going down this path all of a sudden
you're over here and so that's what our
hidden Markov model is going to help us
to determine is basically the
probability that we're on a given Road
given a variety of in coming GPS signals
so this is again something that I
covered very much in depth in the Uber
video but the gist is that we need to
basically keep that sharded hidden marov
model on a bunch of instances of flank
because uh in order to efficiently
process a hidden marov model we need to
use the vur algorithm which is a dynamic
programming algorithm meaning it has to
maintain state from point to point right
so when Point 2 comes in I have to
actually remember where 0. one was uh
otherwise it's not going to be very
useful to me so we basically need to
keep track of our state of our hidden
Markov model as points keep coming in
and uh at least the way that I proposed
doing that was using Kafka and Flink and
basically uh partitioning Flink by
geohash range so that when we get two
GPS signals that are near one another
they go to the same Flink node again not
something I want to go too much into you
can watch the whole video on it but uh
that's the general overview the next
thing is we actually want to be able to
calculate the average Road speed right
so it's one thing to be able to get a
single driver's speed however it's
another thing to actually get the
average speed of all the drivers on that
road now let's say we want to do this
process I don't know every 10 minutes or
every five minutes and actually just
Bunch them all together get that average
and then we can throw that onto our Edge
and update the amount of time that it
takes to Traverse the road cool so in
order to do that obviously we need to
maintain some State because we're
actually going to be taking the average
of these numbers so the way that we can
do this is of course as per usual with
Jordan we're going to be using Kafka and
Flink because we're going to be doing
stream processing we're going to
aggregate these entries using a link
list on a 5 minute interval and what we
can do is actually partition all of this
data by The Edge ID which is effectively
just the ID of the road we get the idea
of the road from that previous step
using our hidden Markov model so now all
of a sudden you know our Flink node is
basically just going to be keeping the
following we've got a link list of all
of the speeds right 22 is pointed to 25
mph 28 m M hour 20 mph uh and then we
can also cach the number of entries that
there are and the number uh of total
miles per hour that we're seeing uh the
reason for this being that this is just
an efficient algorithm to quickly get
the average right so for me to get the
average I just do 95 divid
4 um that's a percentage sign gez I'm
tired and so the the point here is that
you know you can quickly compute the
average when a new entry comes in let's
say uh 21 entry uh 21 miles an hour
comes in then we would say entries is
now five the total is now going to be uh
let's see 116 and then if we needed to
compute the average we could quickly do
so similarly if uh the 20 M hour was
outside of the active time range right
it's older than 5 minutes we can remove
it from our link list very easily
because it's at the edge of it and
that's going to be 0 of one for removing
we can subtract the number of entries by
one now we're back to four and now all
of a sudden we are back to 96 in terms
of our total so hopefully you understand
my rationale behind uh basically
algorithmically efficient uh data
structures in flank here for calculating
that average cool the next aspect of
this is going to be the concept of
bubbling up right so the idea here is
that if we have a shortcut Road and the
shortcut road is made up of a variety of
individual real roads if one of those
real roads all of a sudden gets a ton of
traffic on it we may want to update that
shortcut Edge because all of a sudden we
don't want all of our cars being routed
through that traffic we'd to wrap them
elsewhere so keep in mind that not only
can we have a road right here we can
have a shortcut Edge that depends on it
and we can even have a second shortcut
Edge that depends on the first one
because like I mentioned if we have
multiple different layers of sparse
graphs we may actually want to take
shortcut edges and make shortcut edges
out of them which is pretty
interesting cool so again the idea here
is the ETA is constantly changing right
like I said every couple of minutes
maybe even every few seconds depending
on how you configure things you're going
going to be updating the ETA of this
particular Road right here but ideally
we don't want to have to constantly be
recalculating all of our shortcut edges
because that's just going to be a
complex process it's a lot of dyr
searching so the question is when should
we check when we should actually update
a shortcut Edge ideally we should just
do it if uh this guy increases by some
Delta and then it leads to the shortcut
Edge in turn having an ETA increase by
some threshold right so if shortcut one
happen to go from 10 minutes to 12
minutes in terms of the estimated amount
of time to drive through it maybe
perhaps we should look to see if we can
use a different uh sequence of roads to
recompute shortcut one for the same
start and end
point cool so let's continue talking
about actually doing some bubbling up so
the first thing that I want to do is uh
basically create a database of
dependencies as far as shortcut edges
are concerned so imagine we have some
Edge called 12 right so that's the ID of
the edge and we create a shortcut Edge
that includes it and that eventually
gets given the ID 46 now keep in mind
the shortcut edges have multiple
dependencies right so 46 is here again
this time it depends on edge 13 and look
at that it happens to also depend on
edge 14 now note that if uh we have this
even bigger shortcut Edge called 197 it
could depend on 12 13 14 and possibly
even you know 15 16 17 and the point is
we want to be able to keep track of
these dependencies so that we know to
update shortcut edges when we get a new
ETA of basically uh one of our actual
roads or our actual
edges so for this type of thing I don't
think we're going to be updating it too
frequently so I think it's pretty
reasonable to just use a typical mySQL
database uh again reads don't have to be
super fast on it writes don't have to be
super fast on it because they're not
going to come in that often and frankly
I don't even want to read from this
database table the reason I'm keeping a
database table in the first place is is
because I ultimately want to pipe all of
this data into our Flink dist uh into
our Flink node from over here so we can
actually use change data capture to
basically pipe all of that data into
Flink and then say Oh wait a second you
just got an update on Road 12 I'm
looking over here I see that 46 depends
on 12 and 197 depends on 12 looks like
we're going to have to update those
values as
well so how is this actually going to
look like from the perspective of a
diagram let's check it out so like I
mentioned before our full graph right
the non-compacted one at all is going to
use neo4j I'm sure this is going to have
a ton of partitions but for now I'm just
representing it as one we've also got
our sparse graph which is in memory and
then we've also got our super sparse
graph which is in memory now I'm sure
the sparse graph probably will need a
few different partitions maybe if we're
lucky the super sparse graph can only be
stored on one partition uh but hard to
say without actually doing this type of
thing in practice so the first thing to
note is that again we've got Flink down
here in the middle of our graph because
this is where all of the updates are
coming in so keep in mind that Flink
knows from the prior example if we're
just continuing that that Road 12 is
part of both Road 46 and
197 cool then it's also getting speed
updates from Kafka right basically we
have our service from before that hidden
Markov Service uh putting speed updates
for a given Road ID into Kafka and Flint
can be partitioned on the road ID so
that you know for a given Road we're
making sure it's receiving all of those
speed updates so in the last 5 minutes
let's say we see that one car is going
10 m hour on Road 12 one car is going 8
m hour on Road 12 so now all of a sudden
our 5 minute timer hits we want to
actually update our Edge great so the
first thing that we do is we go to the
full graph and we say Okay Road 12 is
now getting 9 M hour the next thing that
we do is we're actually going to go to
our sparse graph in memory and do the
same thing because we know that 46 is in
the sparse graph so we have to say Hey
you know Road 12 is going 9 miles an
hour update the edge uh for the ETA of
Road 46 uh respectively and the next
thing is that we also want to be uh
updating our super sparse graph because
that's where Road 197 is so now we're
going to say uh Hey Road 12 is 9 M hour
or rather than do that you know we would
just basically say you know 196 is going
up by you know 2 minutes or something
because we can keep track of how long uh
Road 12 is and then we just multiply the
Delta of the speed with the length of
the road cool so the next thing that
we're going to do there is basically say
okay well shoot all of a sudden uh Road
46 just became a lot slower now I have
to find a new path for it so the way
that we would actually find A New Path
for Road 46 is we would take the two
points that Road 46 was connecting right
so let's imagine this was 46
and it has some start and some end now
all of a sudden we actually go to the
full graph because the full graph is
going to have all the different roads
between these same two points right you
know we've got all of these different
ways of getting there and so now that's
going to return us basically the best
possible way that we can re uh recreate
that shortcut Edge and then once we do
that we can actually go right over to
here in the shortcut dependencies table
and update that so let's say now all of
a sudden you know Road 46 is no longer
dependent on Road 12 but is now
dependent on Road 9 and Road
16 this change is going to pipe through
our change data capture we're going to
see that Road 12 is no longer a part of
Road 46 in Flink and then all of a
sudden we can cross that out and so now
whenever we get subsequent updates to
the speed of Road 12 we are not going to
be doing any updates over here hopefully
that makes some general
sense okay so last part of this as my
throat begins to kill me is just going
over the full design once more right
over here we've got our
driver where the first thing that they
want to do is actually go ahead and
calculate their root so like we just
showed above there are three different
tables that they can go to there's the
full map for close distances there's the
sparse map for medium distances there's
the super sparse map for large distances
now I haven't shown off how we're
actually partitioning any of these
tables but ideally they are going to be
partitioned by either geohash use single
leiter replication and of course if
there're particularly hot partitions we
can either add a bunch of replicas or
you know treat particularly hot
partitions and split them out so that
for example New York City is on its own
partition but then all of the middle of
the United States is also on its own
partition cool hopefully that part makes
sense the next piece of that is once
we're actually driving we want to be uh
hitting our traffic update service so
the point here is that this guy is
constantly sending pings via GPS signal
now the first thing that this is going
to do is go into Kafka and subsequently
into flank now this is where we're going
to bring back in the service that we
introduced in our Uber video which is
going to be all of our road transition
and emission probabilities so that we
can basically calculate a GPS signal and
then convert it to a road ID and then
now all of a sudden we can basically say
oh we have a given speed for that road
ID and we're putting the speed for the
road ID into Kafka now Kafka is very
nice in the sense that it is going to do
all of our uh partitioning for us and so
assuming that we partition this guy by
our road ID and our Flint consumer doing
the same now all of a sudden we can
basically say oh okay you know what Road
12 is now taking 10 minutes instead of
its previous 8 minutes so now I can
update all of the relevant things that
care about 12 if uh 12 is cared about by
46 and
197 we're going to update over here in
the super sparse map we're going to
update over here in the sparse map and
we're going to update Road 12 over here
in the full map then finally we may have
to do some actual Edge recomputations if
one of our shortcut edges took a while
longer to calculate at which point this
guy would depend on this guy this guy
would depend on this guy and then if
they do end up calculating new edges
that would end up being propagated to
our shortcut Edge dependency MySQL table
we can just use single leiter
replication here this isn't going to be
happening that frequently again we can
do all of our partitioning by our short
Edge ID uh just so that you know it's
nice and easy to pull all of those at
once and then finally via change data
capture and
Kafka those are all going to get piped
back into our Flink for subsequent speed
updates all right guys I hope this was a
decently good video I think it is a
major improvement over the last time I
covered Google Maps in the sense that uh
I didn't really cover any of this stuff
um you know regarding the shortcut edges
and actually bubbling them up and
propagating them and dealing with the
etas I just kind of briefly mentioned
contraction hierarchies and uh when I
did some more research that seemed
pretty uh insufficient to me
additionally um there are definitely
other videos on YouTube out there who do
cover this stuff but I don't think they
actually cover the implementation
details of it they just cover like a
very high level algorithm and uh I think
it's useful to kind of draw out how we
would actually get this done so guys I
hope you have a nice night uh sorry for
all the stuttering on my end I'm
freaking tired but I will see you in the
next one